hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 39 of game
programming so today we're going to take
a look at the anti T framework and sort
of how we're going to pretty much use
entities in our game so first of all
what is an entity and NC is it's
actually really hard to define what an
entity is because it kind of depends on
really what you define an entity being
because the thing is technically you
could I don't know make time and entity
right so for example if you were using
something like game maker and I do have
some experience with game maker because
I actually haven't used game maker in
about five years but six years ago I
actually entered a game competition and
obviously you know didn't really know
programming language right then so I
used game maker but the thing is I'm in
game maker for example just so you guys
can sort of relate well we you sort of
create objects for everything you do
kind of like programming I guess but
what you do is you sort of there pretty
much cool answer to entities so in other
words if I wanted something to keep time
of my you know if I wanted something to
just keep time of something so like
physical like to measure time then I
would still create an object that would
matter time and I would pop it into my
level but it just wouldn't have a sprite
so being visible but it would still
actually physically be in my room
I guess as they were called again maybe
can make has changed but this was the
gaming version six I think back in the
day me like six years ago um so yeah you
know you'd still like create I guess
time is an entity and you'd actually
physically place it into your level but
it just wouldn't have a sprites or
wouldn't render it's not exactly how
things work here because you know we
obviously have to actually create the
fact that it can have a sprite or not
and something like time just wouldn't it
would just be a separate object running
in the background now so what an entity
is is it doesn't necessarily have to
have a sprite okay I'm not going to
force that upon it but what it does have
to do is it needs to get rendered in
some way and you guys might be like well
hang on a minute it does
have to have a sprite you know what is
it rendering and that's hard to explain
but I'll you know I guess I'll sort of
show you guys and you'll see what I mean
so over here in in in our rain directory
over here in the Navigator I'm just
going to like right click here on the
rain folder hit new class because we're
going to create our own package for this
and it's going to be called entity
because entities are you know pretty
damn important they're going to be like
their own that there are their own like
whole structure so and what's going to
call it entity and that is the entity
class so what doesn't actually have now
an entity and entity has an x and y an
NT and current say entity has a few
things they can be it okay I'm not sure
that okay let's just let's do this so
public boolean removed equals false in
fact I might make this private so
something like removed basically means
if it's been removed from the level or
not suppose that so it's also going to
have because entity sort of are in
levels it's also going to have protected
level variable and that's probably gonna
be enough now I might also give it a
final random protected random variable
just because we will use random for
things like AI in the future so yeah
let's just roll shift over to import
everything here and we will see import
our version of level not Javas and there
you go
so all of these things I wanted to work
now
X&Y this stuff is sort of redundant if
your entity is not going to have a
sprite but I don't really want to split
this up into two file to it into like
two classes where one sort of has you
know spriter one doesn't so I'm just
going to pop it here anyway
yeah but the other methods that entity
has to have is update now this update
method is actually if we go back into
our game classes update method is going
to link right into our update method in
our original thing so in other words
what I mean is the update method will
actually be running at 60 frames a
second at 60 updates or other per second
it's going to be run ah it's going to be
ran at 60 times every second and our
render method is obviously going to be
you know ran as as much as we can
unless we you know unless the player
chooses to limit it to 60 by using out
of a sink or something on that um
Emilie's plus screen so yeah public word
render is just going to have screen
screen so you can see that we don't
actually have where to render it
we've got screen screen and the reason
is the empty entities move tiles down
exactly move you know we sort of just
browse through them I guess whereas
entities actually you know they actually
move that's why they've got their own
X&Y although they don't necessarily have
to move but you know they can so we
don't really want to constrict it to
that remember what it was sort of trying
to by creating this this is this is
really an abstract class by creating you
know this abstract class we're basically
saying that you know um it you know just
like out it's like our template so yeah
public would remove now this is very
important because this was actually was
going to remove an entity from our level
so we obviously have to we can't
obviously do that now we will set remove
it equal to true just so that if we
check that we can actually check it in
fact I will make this public well
this work I'll keep a private just for
purposes but if I do is removed and I
make it a bull in poops um then you know
basically return removed and there you
go
so that will basically you know check
that's removed or not but and you know
we can still keep this private to not
cause confusion now over here is where
we'll actually oops that lagged a lot
remove from level this is actually where
we're going to remove the actual entity
from our level so in other words you
know we have actually made that made
that meth lab yeah we're going to talk a
lot about removing in the future not now
though because this this is sort of
where this series is going to start
getting complicated and one of the
reasons it's going to start getting
complicated it's just because of the
sheer amount of ways you can do the same
thing okay so just a quick disclaimer as
this series progresses this is my way of
doing everything now I've seen over the
past episodes people of being like I why
don't you just do this and a lot of a
lot of reasons I don't take the simple
path all the time is because of
performance people don't realize that
doing things with less code doesn't
necessarily meet or run faster it'll you
know run cleaner I guess if you do
things with less code you could end up
actually running slower and even if it's
a couple hundred FPS that makes a big
difference because you can do it as a
percentage um and it's it's really
important to try and maximize
performances sometimes I'll actually you
know do things the long way but it in
the end you know you get fast
performance and the other thing is um
yeah so again another disclaimer the
rest of this series it's going to be my
opinion
um and what I found works and what I
found is is um was the right word is
versatile enough to actually use
the fort for our for our game so yeah
but anyway that is the end of this
episode guys I hope you enjoyed it
please hit the like button if you did
and next time we'll probably move on to
actually creating a player class and
creating our little player on the
screens also you guys next time
bye
you